in fact adds high security green zone
has been hit by shelling the explosions
follow a day of deadly clashes in the
Iraqi Capital after Shiite cleric
muktada al-sada said he was leaving
politics
[Music]
it's unclear who was behind the attacks
on the international diplomatic Zone
earlier in the day at least 23 of
Santa's supporters were killed amid
clashes after crowds stormed the
presidential Palace inside the green
zone
the violence comes as Iraq remains
gripped in a political crisis that has
left it without a government since
elections last October
[Applause]
supporters of Iraq's Shia cleric muktada
al-sadar breached baghdad's heavily
fortified green zone
an area home to Ministries and embassies
they soon overran the Government Palace
our Revolution is solely an Iraqi one
it's not satrist this is an Iraqi
Revolution
Iraq should be returned to its people
our demands are to dissolve parliament
and to hold the corrupt to accountant we
say to al-sadra we will sacrifice for
you Victory Is Ours
while they were inside many were seen
lounging in meeting rooms used by Iraqi
heads of state
and cooling off in a swimming pool in
the garden
they were soon driven out by Security
Forces using tear gas and gunshots
mission to Iraq as well as the United
States called on all sides for restraint
the flare-up of violence follows months
of political deadlock in Iraq
was the biggest winner in October's
election
but he failed to form a government that
excluded his Shia arrivals close to Iran
he withdrew his lawmakers from
parliament in June
his followers have since been staging a
sit-in outside the parliament
calling for fresh elections
well this isn't the first time the
influential correct has withdrawn from
Politics
the current deadlock in Iraq appears
harder to resolve than in the past
DW spoke to Daniel serware a professor
at the Johns Hopkins school of advanced
International Studies we asked him why
it hasn't been possible to form a
government in Iraq
there's a splintering of political
groups in Iraq and uh
was unwilling to form a broad Coalition
he wanted a majoritarian government
Iraq has been ruled by
by broader coalitions since the American
invasion
uh
you know there comes a time for a
majoritarian uh government in a place
like Iraq but he didn't have the votes
and that's what really counts